[Music]
let's go back to our oddball
yeah let it rip how did you unpack that
for yourself I shifted control from my
brain I [__] [__] into a bag
how did you how did you I [__] and
farted
it just follows a protocol this is why
everything in Brian's day is to get up
and follow the routine and the more you
can automate things in your life
I love that
it just does so much random [__] just
casually what's that analyzing his V
Lite Snapback yeah the [__]
yo what's that device that's making my
teeth whiter yeah yeah through the back
of my head yeah I'm actually half lizard
now so this is that the red light I need
yeah yeah yeah dream rage do you party
I want to film a blueprint rager shots
of extra virgin olive oil 80 decibel
music and I have to make sure that the
music's too loud the red lights yeah if
you establish the culture and the rules
of the game everyone's hold on hold on
yeah sorry man you just you kind of
skipped past the pregame part you kind
of just slipped that in there we're just
curious that was his party
shots of olive oil and a silent disco
and I think it's not too loud because
that would [__] your brain or that would
affect your dog with your ears and I
appreciate that [__] because I got
tinnitus so yeah you know I call this
guy weird but the more I watch
I haven't heard anything he said I've
just heard ringing yeah yeah Fair yeah
yeah
that's all I can hear yeah so
yeah if you establish the culture and
the rules of the game everyone's cool
with known rules of the game and so
that's what kind of what you're doing no
way dude if I went to an olive oil party
I'd be [__] pissed what if there's
bread though
now you're winning Cody over okay yeah
yeah I can take a shot of Volvo what the
[__] is this and focaccia bread
[Music]
okay
huh
and then they put the headphones on you
and you'd be like what's this spa music
what the [__] is this turn this [__] up
yeah maybe like no yeah yeah no we can't
sorry give me some more bread then
that's pretty sucked I'm not too much
your body's gonna start to age it's
gonna process the bread too fast dude
that's so funny just being like yeah if
you designate the rules of the party
like everyone's usually cool for it
imagine like having a classic typical La
party and people are pulling up and all
you have is olive oil
and they're like where's the is there
Coke or anything I think that's just
church dude
at least they have red wine at church
yeah true
yeah even even Mormons got milk at the
party yeah exactly I think a lot of us
went through that period we were like
ostracized but then eventually we found
each other built a new group and
hopefully we can make that easier for
other people
how often do you work out it's been an
hour every day I try to flex and stretch
every muscle of the body and never gets
sore so I'm sure I'm probably missing
out on some gains to be made but really
I'm focused on myself
Jesus
this is impossible to look cool on an
elliptical trainer no
yeah it doesn't matter
just doesn't matter dude
I'll I'll give one possible type of
athlete boxer
that can look cool on an elliptical I'll
give it a shot okay I think a pro boxer
might feel a little cool how because
they you can't use the arm things
you can't use those oh yeah if you
Shadow balls yeah and like kind of cool
and when boxers train like you ever seen
a boxer warm up on a treadmill no
they'll spin run backwards like that oh
yeah you know yeah just kind of
comfortable and yeah so if you're just I
would argue that doing that [__] on an
elliptical will make it more stupid
maybe like doing 180s one foot yeah you
just
to the side
like just this
damn you move like that bro
you kind of you kind of swing in that
thing hey bro that's a thug Shaker if I
seen one
yo does this dude have a he has a family
I'm pretty sure
yo that's him in front of his [__]
lizard light no he does that he Suns he
like sits every morning in front of this
light for like 15 minutes things that
heal your your body and again it's easy
to think that what he's doing is not
accessible to us but it is because I
went to visit Dr stickler a longevity
expert here in Austin and he offers a
lot of the things that Brian does to his
patients but way cheaper and he told me
about some really exciting tools that
are becoming accessible to all of us and
will change our life damn
[__] Dr Xavier over here yeah that's
Lex Luthor yeah seriously oh yeah it is
Lex Luthor now I worked in the tech
industry for many years alongside Brian
and I want to start by saying I think
Brian is an absolute [__] [__] all
right he tries to woo you with all these
big mechanical devices and things he
tries to make you feel small he's a
[__] [__] you can come into my
office for 10 bucks I'll set you up on
the same program okay yeah we're gonna
start over here if you're gonna [__] in
this bag and it's more effective
mentally I'm three years old
biologically I'm 80. I've been aging
myself physically faster to prove
eating applesauce
you don't believe me how am I three
years old with a full set of teeth
watch this cuts a cigar
nurse
anyway dramatically what's at the
Forefront of the health industry I think
the best thing is the plasma delusion
dead opposite voice of what I was
thinking it's a plasmapheresis machine
draws the Blood Out spins it down takes
the plasma off and returns to Red cells
it takes out inflammatory cytokines it
will take out aging markers is the
theory that we're looking at rapamycin
is a little capsule people take it once
a week there's a lot of evidence that
actually prolongs healthy longevity rice
do you say ricin is it right you take
rice once a week you'll age a lot slower
because you're dying
no okay I said rapidmines it just makes
you rap better
rapamycin I took 10 tabs I was rapping
nice then
turn my boys to look out to the lake
shot him in the back of the head rapper
Of Mice and Men
nice
I'm in a crisis then I just killed my
bestest friend
unlike Minnetonka I'm telling all myself
again
then he shoots everyone in the room
that's hard thanks dude I don't know if
you remember a show called The Island
but they would pee in the toilet in the
morning and they would poop it would
give them an assessment and alter their
diet
given for the day and other things so
it's immediate feedback and I think
we're getting there because of people
like Brian who pour in so much money all
these things that Brian is doing are
becoming available to us this is what
they call democratization meaning
there's more money pouring in more
companies are launching products get
better and better and every year things
are getting cheaper interventions we did
in 2010 that would cost five thousand
dollars are now like 200 the amount of
time to double knowledge took about 15
years by 2012 it was down to like two
years 2019 it was down to seven months
yeah then with AI That's probably
we gotta do some of this [__] yeah let's
link up with these dudes let's try and
get younger let's link up let's try and
reverse or uh whatever or what is it
into into something age
what did he say uh intuitive age
intrinsic intrinsic let's link up with
these boys hey Leon
Hendrix
make us make us three years old again
yeah so that's what it's that's what
it's all about now I mean that's what
that's what morning routine guys are
yeah dude to be a morning routine guy in
2023 you have to have
um a heavy supply of rapamycin
and you gotta have a [__]
endoesthesis scanner in your bedroom
yeah daily poop tests yeah
and you have to you have to you need
lizard lights every morning I wake up
and I stand under my red light machine
for exactly seven minutes and 30 seconds
this acclimates my body to the earth and
the Earth's atmosphere and temperature
and begins to
metastasize
cauterize and metabolize my body
then I go take a big fat [__]